our subject for this evening how low can
you go
what did i say
how low can you go
in the beginning god created the heaven
and the earth
and the earth was without form and void
and darkness was upon the face of the
deep
and the spirit of god moved upon the
face of the waters
and god said let there be light
and there was light
and god saw the light that it was good
and god divided the light from the
darkness
and god called the light day and the
darkness he called night
and the evening
and the morning
were the first
day
god is good
and all the time
let's listen to genesis 1 3 and 4 again
and god said let there be light
and there was light
now listen very carefully and god saw
the light
that it was good
he did not say that about the darkness
are you with me
god saw the light
that it was good
and god divided the light from the
darkness
bible truth is light
and those who walk in this light
they walk in the light of christ
because he is the light of the world and
he is the word very early in the bible
god tells us i do not want light and
darkness coexisting
and so it is my
determination to present to you
the light of god's word by keeping my
opinions to myself and just giving you
thus saith the lord
god does not want light and darkness
commingling
god called the light good he did not say
that about the darkness
how was your
how have you been since i last saw you
so those of you who were here earlier
well you've survived because here you
are again god bless you i mean that
sincerely
it's uh you have to have an appetite for
spiritual things to come to two services
within the space of three or four hours
so i'm grateful for your presence
even if no one came i would still speak
to the camera but it's always good to
have
living people
occupying the pews it makes a difference
to the preacher or any speaker
is there anyone with us who's not a
seventh adventist apart from my brother
anyone else all right
okay our subject for this evening how
low can you go
what did i say
how low can you go
as always and i hope it's not too
irritating preserve reverence where you
are and you have been doing that and may
the lord bless you for that i say that
very sincerely favor number two pray for
me while i'm speaking do that don't
forget
all i want you to say is lord
put your words in that man's mouth
jeremiah chapter 1 verse 9 then the lord
put forth his hand and touched my mouth
and the lord said unto me behold i
have put my words in thy mouth the words
of god will change your lives
jeremiah as i just told you that's one
of my favorite verses
when god sent moses to speak to pharaoh
moses said i cannot speak that's exodus
4 verse 10 and 11
and god said in verse 12 now therefore
go
i will be with thy mouth
and teach thee what thou shalt say and i
want god to do that for me today
second samuel 23 verse 2 the spirit of
the lord speak by me and his word was in
my tongue i want god's word in my tongue
favor number three think as you listen
good serious thinking is not automatic
good serious thinking must be a
deliberate conscious process it does not
happen reflexively or instinctively what
happens instinctively is faulty thinking
but intelligent thinking requires a
conscious process and so the bible says
come now let us reason together saith
the lord i hope you will do that with me
let us pray
our loving father in heaven we're so
grateful you've preserved our lives unto
this point as we bow in your sacred
presence we ask you that god cleanses
from sin from everything that is unlike
you large and small do this particularly
for me because my duty is to deliver the
words of eternal life i humble myself
before you lay god and i ask you to use
me as you see fit i offer no resistance
whatsoever bless those who've come
give them an understanding of your word
father as you give me simple language if
anyone is sick heal that person their
god if you see fit not to heal give
great relief from all forms of suffering
remove covet 19 from anyone who's
listening to this message who may have
that condition heal that person their
god please but above all heal us from
the virus of sin i pray now dear god i
commit this service to your glory and
your glory alone i off this prayer from
my heart in jesus name let god's people
say amen and amen
genesis chapter two reading from verse
seven
genesis chapter two
reading
verse seven
it's a very well-known verse when you
see it you'll realize you can say it
without looking
and the lord god formed man of the dust
of the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life
and man became
a living soul
let's go to genesis 3
verse 17.
and unto adam he said
because thou has hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife
and has eaten of the tree of which i
commanded thee saying thou shalt not eat
of it curse is the ground for thy sake
in sorrow shalt thou eat of it all the
days of thy life thorns also and thistle
shall it bring forth unto thee and thou
shalt eat the herb of the field in the
sweat of thy face shall thou eat bread
to thou return unto the ground for out
of it was thou taken now read the
lecture words with me
for dust thou art and unto dust shalt
thou return this is god speaking to a
living man
he was alive
he looks at a living man who says you
are dust
and you're going back to where the dust
comes from which is the ground
keep in mind genesis 2 7 and the lord
god formed man of the dust of the ground
we have ground
we have dust
he was made
from the dust
let us go to psalm 103
we read 13 and 14 our subject how low
can you go
it's just about 6 40 i'll release you by
before 7 30.
what book did i say
psalm what chapter
what verses 13 and 14.
like as a father pitteth his children
saw the lord pity of them that fear him
now read 14 with me for he knoweth our
frame he remembereth that we are dust
not that we're ground
he remembereth that we're dust
let's go to malachi chapter 4.
let's read from verse 1.
malachi the very last book of the old
testament
book 39 of the bible
chapter 4 reading from verse 1 our
subject how low can you go
for behold the day cometh that shall do
what burn as an oven and all the proud
yeah all that do wickedly shall be
stubble and the day that cometh shall
burn them up saith lord of hosts that
they shall leave them neither what root
nor branch now when you are so
completely burned up the bible says it
shall leave them neither root nor branch
what is the end result look at verse
three
read that with me
and you shall tread down the wicked
under your feet for they shall be walked
ashes under the soles of your feet in
other words when you're thoroughly
burned the end product is
ashes
which symbolizes
nothing
god tells us in ezekiel 28 verse 18 he
shall bring satan to ashes in the sight
of all those who behold him because we
know from revelation 24 10 he will be
cast into the lake of fire
ashes let's go to genesis 18 let's go
back there genesis 18.
we're looking at ashes
let's read from verse 23.
of genesis 18
you have 23
what is 23 saying
abraham jr and said what
will thou also destroy the righteous
with the wicked per adventure there be
fifty righteous within the city without
also destroy and not spare the place for
the fifty righteous
that are therein that be far from thee
to do after this manner to slay the
righteous with the wicked and that the
righteous should be after the wicked
that be far from thee shall not the
judge of all the earth do right and i
like that very much because abraham is
telling god you cannot destroy righteous
people with wicked people if you do
that's not right you're the judge of the
whole earth you ought to do what's right
now never talk to god like that unless
you have a special relationship
are you with me you won't live very long
abraham was speaking respectfully when
moses told god turned from your fierce
wrath
he had a special relationship with god
he can speak to god that way with holy
boldness with humble boldness all right
verse 26 and the lord said what
if i find in sodom 50 righteous within
the city then i will do what spare all
the place for their sakes now read verse
27 carefully what does that say and
abraham answered and said behold now i
have taken upon me to speak unto the
lord which and but dust and ashes
abraham says look i am only dust on
ashes how can i talk to god like that
i am dust
i am ashes
the bible says
i have you to read about ashes because i
want you to see the company that dust
keeps
you with me
dust and ashes go together in the bible
the lowest forms of anything that's
consumed dust ashes
you get the dust out of your house you
don't plant your your your flowers and
dust you plant your flowers in the
ground we were made from dust
if that's clear say amen
now having said that
remember was it last night yes i told
you the earth was cursed how many times
three times name the first one
when adam sinned
curses the ground for thy sake and the
dust comes from the ground what was the
second curse
when k and k label what was the third
curse when god sent a
flood now the earth is under a triple
curse
keep this in mind go with me now to
genesis 28.
what's your subject
how low
can you go
genesis 28 let's read verse 12 jacob has
fled from his home because his brother
esau wants to kill him for what in the
human context would be a very good
reason he stole his brother's birthright
he stole his blessing and esau's out for
blood
sometimes biological connections do not
save you from wrath esau is out for
blood
uh jacob's mother tells him leave so he
runs off
one night he's sleeping he's there on a
stone
verse 12 genesis 28 let me pray again
father as i continue speak through me
god literally speak through me in jesus
name i appeal to you amen this week
together and he
that's right he dreamed and behold a
ladder set up where
on the earth and the top of it reached
where to heaven now
the latter has two points of contact
was the first one identified
but tell me something about that earth
yes something something else
look at this and see if you got a clue
it is tripoli cursed
the other end of the ladder touches
where
heaven
now and behold the angels of god
ascending and descending upon it that's
what jacob saw
now let the bible explain itself go to
john chapter 1.
john chapter 1 we'll read verse 51 jesus
explains what jacob saw
i love that about the bible sometimes to
understand what genesis says we've got
to go to peter or revelation or
something
that's why when you study the bible you
study here a little
very little light up online precept upon
precept john 1 reading verse 51
are you there
read with me and he saith what unto them
verily verily i say unto you hereafter
ye shall see heaven open and the angels
of god ascending and descending upon the
son of man
now jesus is taking the minds back to
that dream of jacob
what when jacob saw that ladder the
latter symbolized whom
jesus christ
i am the way
the truth and the life no man cometh
unto the father but by me not only that
every blessing from heaven comes through
jesus christ
every prayer that the father receives
has to come through jesus christ
the prayers go up through him the
blessings come to us through him let me
say it more bluntly there is nothing god
can do for you
that he does outside of jesus
everything goes through jesus christ
and so the angels who are ministering
servants according to hebrews chapter 1
verse 14 are they not all ministering
servants sinful to minister to them who
shall be heirs of salvation
it is through christ through christ
through christ
let me get back to the points of contact
of the latter
on the triply cursed earth
and touching heaven
christ became human
he was also god
he was human
he was divine he wasn't almost human the
the the lower end of the ladder did not
come close to the earth it was set up on
the earth let me tell you something else
about christ as i continue with how low
can you go
god said let them make me a sanctuary
that i may dwell among them
the sanctuary had no floor
are you with me
which man when the priest was
officiating where was he walking
on the ground but whom does the priest
represent jesus christ the humanity of
christ christ symbolized by that priest
always in contact
with the ground it was a magnificent
structure
with all the the curtains and and the
silver and the gold and the blue and the
scarlet and the silver and the linen but
the priest walked on the ground
when he ministered
we have a savior
who is both divine
and human
we have a savior who in his humanity
understands what we're going through and
in his divinity he can do something
about it
you and i have friends who understand
what we're going through finish my words
they understand what we're going through
finish my words
they can do nothing about him
they understand you're broke but they're
broke too are you following me they
cannot help you but jesus christ he
understands but he can do something
about it because he's both god
and man what's our subject
keep this in mind let's go to psalm
eight now psalm eight
the eighth psalm
we read from verse three
psalm eight reading from verse three
if i go to quickly just say slow down
when i get excited i do that and that's
not good just say slow down or just
do something and i'll slow right down
are you psalm 8
verse 3
read with me
when i consider thy heavens the works of
thy fingers the moon and the stars which
thou hast ordained keep going what is
man that thou art mindful of him come on
or the son of man that thou visites him
stop the psalmist wants to know you are
the big god
first kings eight let's read 27 i
believe we read it yesterday sometime
i'm sure we did or was it today i don't
recall first kings 8
verse 27 don't lose psalm 8.
first kings 8
verse 27
are you there
read with me but will
indeed dwell aware on the earth now read
the lecture words
the heaven
and heaven of heavens cannot contain him
stop
god's too big for the universe
to house him the heaven and heaven of
heavens cannot contain god
that's why when your god lives in a
building your god is small
you're listening to me if your god can
you can put your god in that little
corner that's a little god can do
nothing for you the god who made heaven
and earth is bigger than heaven on earth
now the psalmist looks up in the sky
he says when i consider
the heavens
the sun
the moon
the stars
what's the name of the closest star to
us
yes the sun that's right i was trying to
trick you i failed yes the sun is
actually a star you when i consider thy
heavens the works of thy fingers the
moon and the stars which thou hast
ordained put in place
why do you waste time
with sinful human being what is man that
thou art mindful of him and the son of
man that thou visites him let me tell
you something christ could come no lower
than when he became human
if christ had become human when adam was
still sinless
that would have been a tremendous
humiliation
for the god that the heavens cannot
contain
to come in the form of a limited created
being even in its sinless state it would
have been a humiliation for christ to
come as an angel he came as a human
being when the earth was triply cursed
let me tell you something else about how
low can you go
christ came why let the bible tell us
one of his reasons matthew 1 21 what
does that say don't look tell me and she
shall
bring forth come on a son and thou shall
call his name jesus why for he shall
save his people from their sins what did
jesus christ say to zacchaeus the son of
man is come to what seek and to save
that which was lost what did john tell
jesus tell his audience in john 6 38 for
i came down from heaven not to do my own
will but the will of the father which
have sent me he came to do the father's
will he came to reflect the father he
came to demonstrate that the law of god
can be perfectly observed
he came to show
what a loving god
can do
with ashes
now this is cursed ashes
he came to demonstrate
to the degree we can grasp
how much he loves us
so as low as god could go
he came down
but let me tell you something else about
how low can you go
go to john 15.
i hope someone has already said and will
continue to say lord put your words in
that man's mouth
john 15
let's read from 12.
do you have that
this is my commandment
that you love one another as i have
loved you
greater love hath no man than this that
a man laid down his life for his friends
stop
we'll read 13 again and i really mean it
when i say read microscopically
read aloud if you have my version
greater love have no in other words
there is no greater way to demonstrate
love than to sacrifice your life for
someone you care about
greater love had no man than this that a
man lay down his life for his friends
now
say with me john 3 16
for god so loved the world stop
greater love so loved are you following
me greater love so love same thing for
god so loved the world
that he did what
he gave his only begotten son now follow
me closely
what did john 15 13 say that if you
truly love what will you do
you'll give your life
not somebody else's
if uh
let's say my wife is
about to be executed
for keeping the sabbath
and the governor says to me well look
you know if you give your life for her
we let her off we'll kill you instead
then i say to my cousin would you die
for my wife please
have i shown love yes or no no
but she still gets off but i haven't
shown love
god said jesus speaking for god greater
love
hath no man than this that a man lay
down come on his life
but john 3 16 says for god so loved the
world that he seemed to have laid down
his son's life we have is there conflict
no
now the gospel is a magnificent thing no
human being can fully explain it somehow
in jesus what did god do
he gave himself
now listen to the bible god was in
christ come on
reconciling the world to himself but the
foundation of reconciliation is death
romans 5 10 for if while we were enemies
we were reconciled to god by the death
death is required for reconciliation the
bible says god was in christ reconciling
himself all i can say as a limited human
being somehow
god the father gave himself through
jesus christ
how low can you go
let's take another look but let me pray
again father
restrain me
remind me i'm here for your glory not
mine
give me the words father in jesus name i
pray amen
let's look at something else
go with me to james chapter one no uh
first timothy chapter six verse 16.
our subject how low can you go first
timothy 6
16.
do you have that
all young men you know ella white said
timothy was a teenager when the lord
called him
to serve paul tremendous honor
teenagers can be serious for god
if they're challenged
but if all we expect him to do is play
video games that's all they will do we
take people tend to live up to
expectations however low they may be we
live up to them first timothy chapter
six do you have that
verse 16 what does that say who
only hath immortality stop that's god
god
has immortality
is life he doesn't just have life he is
life all life is connected to god
nothing can live apart from god he is
and has immortality meaning that god
cannot walk
die
you see the mystery yet he gave himself
through jesus
but divinity can't die let's learn
something else let's go to james chapter
one
james chapter one
this is one of the half brothers of
christ who wrote a book in the bible who
was the other person
jude
james one let's read from verse 13.
when you found it someone alert me by
saying amen
temptation
to save those who were subject to death
and temptation
because he became like those he saved
he said again divinity had to divide
away
how can i experience that
what
yes
am i not the god the heavens cannot
contain yes
[Music]
i'm coming
and so christ came
from verse one
and the lord appeared to him in the
plane of memory and he sat in
what time
in the heat of
everybody
you're from york
is relaxing
and what happens
he lifted his eyes and
and behold what three men
stood by him
and when he saw them he did what he ran
to meet him and bowed himself with his
bowed himself to the ground now we know
the three men were christ and two
engines
now here is christ
in human form
are you with me
how do we know he's in human form let's
go to verse
seven and we read verse eight
are you verse seven
what did i say and abraham
right into the herd and fetched a cuff
tender and good and he gave it unto a
young man and he hastened to dress it
verse eight
he took the calf which he dressed butter
and milk and the caffeinated dress and
did what set it before them and she
stood by them and they did it here's
abraham
you know this is very interesting you go
to a good restaurant i mean a five-star
restaurant
the waiter comes to you especially if
you
and he has a napkin over his uh
are you following me yeah i mean classy
restaurants not mcdonald's and wendy's
classy restaurant he has something over
there so he could you know
abraham i see him
abraham had hundreds of servants
remember when lot was taken captive by
four kings from the other side
abraham armed 318 men
those are men old enough to fight what
were the younger boys and the older men
he had hundreds of servants abraham
himself
servant
didn't know who they were
talk about hospitality and humility now
if it were me i wouldn't know who are
you
if i know who you are you're high enough
i'll do it you know enough i get
somebody else or if abraham did it
himself now he stood by them under the
tree finish verse 8.
eating is what human beings do
we're discussing how low
can you go
but i want to point something out to you
abraham
christ took
human form
when he came to abraham
not human nature
and every few seconds to think
he took human
form
not human nature when he appeared to
abraham
he took human nature when he came
through a woman
ah now we have the law of
heredity and inheritance he took human
form when he came through a woman
born of a virgin mary in the new
testament but his appearance in genesis
18 he came in human form
not human nature
and so even though that was a
humiliation of itself it was not as low
as when he actually came after nine
months in the womb of a woman
why
to save us
let me ask you this
the bible says in the beginning god
created the heaven and the earth am i
right yes
revelation 21 1 then i saw a new heaven
and a new earth what does that tell us
christ's will remake the heavens and the
earth sin uh
contaminated the first version he will
remake them which means god could have
remade
adam and eve
are you following me back in the garden
you gotta wipe them out and start it all
over
you who he who creates can recreate am i
clear
no
i want to save them
but they've sinned i know
but to sin you have to become one of
them
in nature not behavior are you following
me
in nature
you must assume they're limited
capacities
and you're the mighty god
go to isaiah 9 let's try to emphasize
what i'm saying isaiah 9 we read verse
6.
isaiah chapter 9 reading for six hour
subject how low can you go
are you there
read with me for unto us
a child is born unto us a son is given
and the government shall be where upon
his shoulders and what
his name shall be called what wonderful
come on counselor come on
the mighty god come on you have a
lasting father and the principal give me
those five names again his name shall be
called wonderful what else
counselor what else mighty god what else
everlasting let's pause on everlasting
father
some people use that to say well christ
and the father the same no everlasting
father means the father of
everlastingness
the father of eternity in other words
eternity came from god
eternity came from christ
who was one with the father
that's how high we're talking about this
being who came down he is the source
of eternity
what does eternity
mean never no end
he is the source
of eternity
and he came in a condition
of what
does but think of eternity give me the
opposite
if it's not eternal it's what
it's finite
it's finite it's limited it's temporary
it's restricted
restricting the god
whom the universe cannot contain why
give me one word
love
for whom
for me
it's nice to say us but for me
understand the love of god is personally
targeted at you
the mighty god
the everlasting father the one from whom
eternity flows
he came
go with me now to hebrews chapter 2.
hebrews 2
we're looking at this christ and how he
was made
keep in mind
psalm 8 verse 3
which we read now hebrews 2 verse 9. do
you have that
what does the bible say but we see
jesus who was made how a little lower
than the angels come on crown with what
for the seven of that crown with glory
and honor that he
by the grace of god finish the verse
should test death for every man but what
did we read in first timothy 6 16 god
alone hath immortality
only a divine being
has immortality yet this divine being
found a way to taste death
try to understand how god hates death
death was never a part of god's plan
when he created
that's why death is the last enemy that
shall be destroyed
death and jesus
tasted
death
for everyone
you know when he tasted that death
in the garden of gethsemane
now you have to listen very carefully
and may god give me the right words as i
try to speak this truth
the bible says the dead
know
nothing are you with me
a dead person cannot death often brings
an end to suffering
that's why we have something called
euthanasia
phthanasia sanatopsis death and you
means good good death it ends suffering
pull the plug
end suffering
so on the cross when christ died his
suffering ended in the garden
that's where he tasted death
when he told the disciples
in matthew 26 38 i believe it is my soul
is exceeding sorrowful even
i am tasting death i am experiencing
death while i'm alive
why
because he loves you
and christ died on that cross
it wasn't make believe death he died
that's one of the reasons he took on
humanity to experience death now go with
me to revelation one let's read from
verse 17.
our subject how low can you go
revelation 1 reading verse 17.
this is john who was the youngest of the
12 disciples this is about 70 years
later 60 to 70 christ appears to him on
the island of patmos
john is probably 80 at the time
he hadn't seen jesus i heard his voice
for 60 years
verse 17 says when i saw him come on i
fell at his feet as dead
and he laid his right hand upon me
saying unto me fear not i am the first
and the last i am he that
and
and now what
forevermore i am he that liveth and
was
dead who is speaking jesus christ i was
dead
when i began speaking i said
i recited from genesis 1 in the
beginning god created the heaven and the
earth and i went to verse 3 and god said
let they be like do you know who that
was who said god let there be light
jesus
let the earth bring forth grass that was
jesus and grass is a living thing
who said lazarus come forth jesus
what did jesus say to martha i am the
resurrection and the life that's what i
am
what did he say in john 14 6 i am the
way i am the truth i am the life what
did he tell the pharisees in john 5 40
you will not come to me that you might
have life
what is first john 5 verse 12 says he to
have the son hath life
this is the one who said i was dead
it's a terrible price that god paid
christ paid the holy spirit paid because
hebrews 9 verse 14 tells us christ
through the eternal spirit offered
himself without spot to the father
god was in christ reconciling the world
to himself
christ said i was dead
he offered himself to the spirit
the family of heaven
paid and suffered
why
because god loves you
when you think of that this verse makes
more sense
how shall we escape
if we neglect
so great salvation
god came as low as he could come in the
person of his son christ
and through the sufferings of christ
the father himself gave himself for our
salvation why because he loves us and he
wants us with him and this is the i
often say this in my sermons recite john
3 16 for me for god so loved the world
that he gave his only begotten son
here's what i always remind god's people
for god so loved the world
that's the world there that front pew
that he gave his only begotten son
that's the sun that pew on the left
you know what the verse could have said
for god so loved his son
that he gave up the world
it doesn't say that
he said for god so loved you
that he gave up christ
when christ was in gethsemane he said
father if thou be willing do what
remove this suffering from me
but you see the law says the soul that
sinneth it shall die
someone had to take that suffering
if the father had removed it from christ
he would have given it
to the world
so he told christ you drink it
on the cross
jesus said my god my god finish it for
me why hast thou forsaken me
if the father had not forsaken christ he
would have had to forsake the world
at every step the father chose the world
let me be more personal at every step he
chose you
his son crying father i'm suffering
and the father says but i want to save
them so you suffer
why have you forsaken me because i don't
want to forsake them
let me close by saying
god was willing
to go through eternity
without jesus
but not without us
let me change my phraseology god was
willing to go through eternity without
jesus but not without you
or without me
how low can you go as low as was
necessary to save a dying world and he
made that sacrifice while we were weak
while we were enemies while we were
sinners
and this the purpose of this is for us
when we contemplate how low god came
it should soften the heart
and cause us
to fall at his feet
when a rich young ruler not a rich young
ruler the young prodigal son
when he realized his condition he came
back
when the father kissed him he said make
me a servant just make me make me low
make me low
the father said no
i'm going to treat you as though you
never left
put a best robe on him a ring on his
hand not promoting jewelry but the ring
was how people stamped and signed you
signed with a ring and shoes on his feet
the servants went without shoes my son
cannot be the father treated him as a
member of the royal family you can act
as though you never left
he said make me low the father said no
jesus came low
that he might raise us
high
let me tell you how high
go to colossians 3
and then i'll close this message how low
can you go colossians 3
we read from verse 1
while you're searching i'll pray father
i'm about to close i ask you lord to
give me an extra outpouring of your
power for your glory and the blessing of
your people in jesus name i pray amen
colossians 3 reading from verse 1 if ye
then be risen with christ seek those
things where which are above which
christ saith where on the right hand of
yes
now
keep in mind where christ sits on the
right hand of god what did i say the
right hand of god that's where he sits
symbolically representing his power now
go to ephesians 2.
ephesians chapter 2
remember what colossians says christ
sits on the right hand of god that's
also what stephen saw him envision in
acts chapter seven
ephesians two
let's read from verse four
when you found that say amen
but god who is rich in mercy for his
great love wherewith he loved us even
when we were
dead in sin hath quickness together how
and hath raised by gracious saved and
hath raised us up together and made us
do what sit together come on in heavenly
places come on in christ jesus now or
through christ jesus where is christ
and where are we to be
how
because we are aware
in christ yes
this is no symbolic language
you and i
through faith in christ
we sit
on the right hand of god
from dust
to the throne of god in christ
no angel
has that privilege
ah the love of god love has no bounds
what else can god do
but put us in christ
right next to him
that's what the mother of james and john
wanted
grant that one of my sons on the left
one on the right christ said that's not
for me to give that's my father
anyone who's saved through christ that's
the only way
the eventual
award is a place next to the father
in
jesus christ but that's our place now
by faith
one day
what we now accept by faith
we shall accept in actual
three-dimensional reality
we shall be through christ in christ
right
next to the father occupying a position
of privilege not even angels can enjoy
how low
can you go
christ came as low as he could come
and the father came through him
that he may raise us
to as high
as he can take us
the only limitation that will be on the
saved will be we cannot be god
but we will be as close to god as
possible
how many of you will say father
i recommit my life to christ
seat me
in christ
at your right hand of power can i see
your hand please
when you sit there how can you allow sin
to conquer you over and over and that's
where you sit it let me ask you this
if you attended beckingham palace you
were invited you sit right next to the
queen would you break out a cigarette
even though you're addicted to you would
not
the power of her presence will control
your behavior
when you're driving the highway
and you notice the cars are slowing up
you can probably guess what's up front
a police cruiser yes i've seen it so
many times traffic just slows down why i
can't speed in his presence source
by faith
we sit on the right hand of god in
christ
let's pray father in heaven
hey dave the psalmist said these things
are too wonderful for me
but we're still to study them
we thank you thank god for coming so
lord through your son
we thank you for the terrible price you
paid
for our salvation
forgive us again god for the many times
we've let you down
we thank you that through christ we may
sit on your right hand now my faith
and in the world to come in actuality
in christ
please father
help us to live with the consciousness
that he or she who is in christ is
seated next to you and our consciousness
of your presence shall exert a
restraining force upon us
fill our hearts with gratitude for your
love dear god thank you so much
thank you for providing salvation
thank you for suffering all the
indignity and the insults and the
humiliation and the shame and the
disgrace even unto death not just any
death the death of the cross
we thank you dear god
we ask you to renew us again
fill us with your spirit
fill our hearts with hatred for sin and
a love for righteousness a love for
righteousness that has no bounds
as we leave
let us leave in a state of gratitude for
your goodness and your love
hasten that day there god
when you will actually place us as high
as you can take us
until then keep us faithful i pray in
jesus name let god's people say amen
and amen
[Music]
you